all right everybody's here time for some
devious [__] shut up well just be
patient what are you talking about
nothing um hey everyone this is amazing
well we got good participation yeah but
um what exactly are we supposed to do
just stand around uh just take lots of
pictures and videos all right all these
people are gonna make a huge impression
once we post about this for an isosceles
triangle that
is out here rallying behind former
Bellaire Academy teacher Miss danetta
Hughes inspires you to use your voice
and rally for her reinstatement
thank you so much for your support
okay yeah I feel really really good
about that that video is boring as [__]
get a picture of this we promise no
signs well yeah I got you I'll post this
guy big I like things
[__] uh excuse me
are you serious like you should be
getting that on camera
yeah just um
um
[Music]
thank you
did you see that they took away the
banner but you can still do the speech
speech yeah like we talked about just
jump up on a table and start talking
that's a great idea
even if they drag you away just we'll
just record it and it'll have the same
effect Carlton what are you waiting for
you totally do that okay okay yeah so
yeah just uh just give me a second okay
you're fine I'm fine
just just just give me a second just
[__] Carlton where are you what the hell
is wrong with him
oh
[__]
Carlton we're trying to fight assistant
here founders award this is
Yo see
what happened to all the signs in the
speeches and all that
I can't I mean you can I can't do the
[__] speech well Carlton you have all
these people out here waiting for
something you better not [__] tell
Mom and Dad okay please I'm letting
everyone down
okay okay
Carlton look
it's gonna be all right okay
I got you
let's breathe
[__]
[Music]
all right everyone thank you for
participating now it's time to get back
to class start heading back to
the point's been made let's all get back
inside let's go come on let's all get
back inside back to class let's hustle
back to class
[Music]
hey look look guys
yo is that will yeah it is
what's he doing
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
he did it
actually please put away your phone
Ashley he did
he did it just take a seat Ashley
Banks
black teachers
[Music]
friends
foreign
[Music]